the past week has seen a dramatic
shake-up in the race for the Democratic
presidential nomination five candidates
have left the race following pivotal
contests in South Carolina and on Super
Tuesday Joe Biden has a chance to
continue the momentum he picked up in
those contests this coming Tuesday when
six more states vote Biden is leading in
the delegate race over Bernie Sanders
they are the last two major candidates
left in the race as Nikole Killion
reports they're now taking aim at each
other I'm here tonight to ask for your
support Bernie Sanders rallied over six
thousand supporters Friday night in
Detroit it was the first of several
stops on a weekend campaign swing
through the Great Lakes State if we are
going to defeat Trump in Michigan in
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin it will be
very hard for a candidate who voted for
these disastrous trade agreements now
trailing in delegates the Vermont
senator kept up his attacks on newly
minted frontrunner Joe Biden from trade
to his position on federal funding for
abortions and he accused the former vice
president of trying to cut Social
Security
Biden responded on Twitter get real
Bernie since is Super Tuesday triumphs
Biden has been on a tear
raising 22 million dollars and racking
up a slew of high-profile endorsements
the latest came from former presidential
candidates John Delaney and Duval
Patrick as well as Chicago Mayor Lori
Lightfoot
[Applause]
Sanders spoke out after an incident at
his Phoenix rally Thursday a man
displayed a Nazi flag sparking
widespread condemnation to have in the
United States of America somebody
bringing forth the most detestable
symbol in modern history a symbol of
which over 400,000 brave Americans died
trying to defeat his unspeakable Biden
sympathized with Sanders I don't care
who you're supporting attacks like this
against a man who could be the first
Jewish president are disgusting and
beyond the pale Nikole Killion CBS News
Washington